[Musique]
nous protégeons la Terre de la racaille de
l'univers avec des agents dans toutes les grandes
villes du monde certains plus
décorés que d'autres HNH
tu es l'un des meilleurs à avoir jamais porté le
costume mais tu auras besoin d'un partenaire
comme Mullen MIB
nous avons un problème à Londres, allez, le
monde ne va pas se sauver, dites-
vous que vous avez besoin de moi pour sauver
le monde, appelez-le, tirez-le,
non, la paperasse est un cauchemar
[Applaudissements]
car vous pourriez tous juste le crime ici
juste  essayez,
ce sera amusant, j'adore m'amuser, il
devrait y avoir un gros bouton rouge ici
quelque part chez
vous